Hi, I'm Christina Win. I'm the director
of communications here at Austin ISD.
And so I'll just take you through um a
little bit of the beginning of the
presentation and then uh Matias should
be here uh shortly.
So here is the agenda. We just had our
principal welcome. Um and we'll go
through some review of the meeting norms
and the purpose. Um we know these are
really difficult conversations and a lot
has been going on. a lot of new ideas
have come about and so that's why we're
really here to hear that feedback and
make sure that any decision we make in
that released plan on Friday is
inclusive of the voices by everyone
affected. Um, and so we will provide
that overview of the campus specific
proposed changes. And then really the
majority of this time is going to be Q&A
with the superintendent. And we also
have our assistant superintendent of
elementary schools, um, Jennifer Pay
over here, and we have the executive
director, um, Sandre McWills.
And so, um, I will work to get y'all,
um, to that Q&A as quickly as I can.
So, here are the meeting norms. um we
have visited um many campuses and have
um shared these norms with them. So um
again acknowledging that these are not
easy conversations but we really want to
focus together on like hearing each
other, hearing your feedback and then
figuring out how we can incorporate that
into the plan. Um honor each other's
time um to get to make sure that we are
able to get as many questions as
possible. like we would love if you
could try to limit to one minute um to
make sure that we can get your questions
answered and we can get as many
questions answered in this time. Um
honor each other. So making sure that
we're respectful, honor the process. Um
again, like we will do our best to
answer every single question. There may
be um answers that um we don't have yet
or we're still working through. I I
think a lot of that is like with our
transition plans um that will need to be
continued um to work on. And so um just
making sure that we honor the process
and then intent and impact um honoring
the space and voice, staying
solutionoriented and then embracing that
transparency and empathy. Um and that
goes back down to the um difficult
conversations like we are we all care
about the students here in Austin ISD
and I think if we can all come to it
with that understanding it'll be very
helpful
and those are the um norms in Spanish.
So again um we are here uh to respond to
questions via the comment card. um your
principal did give us some of your
questions already so we can um answer
them again gain that shared
understanding of the proposed changes
and then figure out how we can
incorporate that ahead of um the final
document that will be posted Friday and
then voted on by the board on Thursday
next week.
Okay. So at the center of this whole
plan is to ensure every family has
access to an excellent neighborhood
school. Um we know we have amazing
schools in Austin and we want to be sure
that um every student has access to
that. And so really we are trying it
with this plan to get our students in
the best possible learning environments.
So, the the plan that we're here to talk
about today is um as many of y'all may
have heard on October 3rd when we
released the initial plan, we talked
about in having Oak Springs close.
Here's our superintendent. I was just
starting to talk about the plan, but if
I don't know if you want to take over or
you want me to keep going.
>> Yeah, I can talk about it.
>> Here, why don't you?
So, uh, I apologize for being late. I'm
running. Um, so appreciate your grace.
Uh, so, um, as Christina was saying, uh,
the plan, uh, as originally developed,
um, by the administration included, uh,
Oak Springs moving fully into
Blackshere. Uh, one of the things that
we were trying to address as part of
this plan, and forgive me if it's
already been said, were kind of several
things. Did you talk about kind of
feeder pattern alignment? Can you talk
about those things? Okay. Well, one of
the things that we had to absolutely
consider were uh turnaround plans in
those schools that had uh accumulated a
series of unacceptable accountability
ratings. And in this case, uh we know
that there's been lots of great work um
in many of our schools, but there's been
changes in accountability. There's been
um you know, challenges with how the
school district supports our schools.
And ultimately we need to break these
accountability chains and there are only
a few ways in which you can break these.
The state of Texas says that you have
six ways that you can do it. Uh
accountability
uh um kind of turnaround plans are built
after a second year. So let's say that a
school receives an F and then another F.
Then after the second consecutive F,
they have to develop a turnaround plan.
Typically in a um a kind of more
familiar
uh kind of setting, you would have a
year to create the plan and then in year
three, you would implement that plan and
then you would have two years to ensure
that you broke the accountability chain
and that means getting a C or better.
What happened in TW this year is that
because of lawsuits in the state of
Texas, we had 23 accountability drop or
get released in the spring of this year.
And then we had 24 and 25 drop on the
exact same day on August 15th. And so
within five months, we had three years
of ratings hit. And so, uh, what that,
um, h what occurred is a compression of
all these plans having to be submitted.
So, lots of schools did not have the
ability to actually build a two-year
turnaround plan, have a year to um,
develop it, and then implement. That was
kind of just out the window, right? And
that occurred throughout the entire
state of Texas. It is happening
everywhere. And there are hundreds and
hundreds of schools uh, that are kind of
in this um, kind of situation. And so
there are six different things that you
can do to um to break a uh six different
strategies that you can use in your
turnaround plan. You can uh reassign the
school which is you take the students
and reassign them to an A, B or C
school. You can uh restart the school.
Uh that is you come in and you have
certain uh requirements for staffing. Uh
and you have to prove that the principal
had previously demonstrated the ability
of turning around a school. That's what
we call a district managed restart. You
also have a chartner partner, a charter
partner restart. This is an 1882. This
is similar to what we have seen at
Mendes. uh it is a model that we don't
really like um very much. We prefer to
control how we educate our students, but
that is an option that you can use. Uh
you also have um new school or new
campus. Uh and this would be taking like
a middle school and turning it to an EC8
or turning a middle school into a 6
through 12. Like you could do that. Uh
you also have a um a school improvement
model which is where you're really being
intentional about the supports you're
providing but you're not kind of in a
situation where you have to make a more
aggressive uh intervention and that is
really uh for those schools that you've
seen tremendous progress. You're
probably year two not a year three. Uh
and then lastly there's just a closure
like you can just close the school. And
so one of the things that we uh had to
acknowledge is that given where Oak
Springs was, we needed to make sure that
uh we were responsive to the turnaround
plan. Uh and whenever we do this, we
look at well which one of these um
strategies is best for us as a
community, as a school district, and one
that we know we can actually execute so
that we can break the accountability
chain. And after going through uh a lot
of analysis, uh we determined that
moving Oak Springs to Blackshere
uh and then having the students combine
uh and providing the supports,
additional, you know, content
interventionists, instructional coaches,
uh you know, those types of supports
would allow us to break the
accountability chain. So the student the
combined student body would then take
the STAR test uh next year and then
based on those accountability ratings uh
would break Oak Springs um uh chain. So
that's how it works. And so that's how
we arrived at this uh solution, this
draft plan. I also want to be really
really clear that we at the same time we
were looking at underenrollment in an
area. We were looking at uh programs. We
look at demographics of the student
populations to ensure that if we're
going to make a disruption, we're really
understanding, you know, where we need
to provide supports so that we're
focusing on our students and doing it in
a way that aligns with our values. So,
that's how we got to the initial draft
plan. Since then, uh, as I've been
committed to from day one, um, I
absolutely want to make sure that
feedback from our community is
incorporated into the plan. uh
everything that we've done um I hope
that you would see in our work whether
it's the bond work the tax rate
elections just how we work in general we
are always trying to incorporate
community voice and one of the things
that we heard as we were um sharing this
plan with our community was that um
there was a desire to explore having Oak
Springs come to Blackshere have black
shear um and the schools combined line
and then at a later date move back to
Oak Springs. Uh, one of the driving kind
of forces I would say behind that idea
though it did come to me from community
was the fact that students would end up
in a fully modernized facility, right?
Which what we know is the way that you
educate students now is very different
than than the way we used to 40, 50, 60,
80 years ago in some cases. And so, uh,
as of right now, the Oak Springs bond
project is paused. Um, you know, as we
go through these processes, we have to
really think about ensuring that our,
um, community investments follow the
students. And so, if Oak Springs was to
close, we would want those dollars to to
follow the students um, as they
metriculated through the school system.
So, that's why we paused it. And so we
wanted to have a conversation with the
Blackshirt community after we heard
those ideas from others in the
collective community to um just kind of
share with you what was occurring. I
also want want to be really really clear
that the board vote on uh next Thursday
on the 20th is to um reassign the
students from Oak Springs to Blackshere.
uh that is still going to be the
recommendation because collectively what
we're doing is combining attendance
boundaries, right? The where the school
resides in that attendance boundary
isn't necessarily something the board
has to vote on. Uh that is more work of
the administration. The board is is
required by law to approve boundary
changes. That's that's one of their core
functions. Boundaries, budgets, hiring a
superintendent. uh it's very very kind
of well defined what their their kind of
purview is and so um I I want to be
really clear like there won't be an
answer today right there's not we're not
going to leave this meeting there's
going to be more conversations uh but I
wanted to create the space to ensure
that all community voice got into the
work uh we made adjustments if we needed
to uh but the vote on Thursday next
Thursday is really to to codify the
turnaround plan which includes Oak ings
student population moving to Black
Shear. What occurs after that uh I would
say needs to get resolved fairly quickly
but isn't um required to be incorporated
as part of that vote. So want to make be
really kind of if hopefully that makes
sense and I'm happy to to clarify. I
will say that um maybe some trustees or
maybe some community members would like
it to be part of that vote but it
doesn't have to be. Uh just so you know
I'm totally transparent about all the
things. All right. So, I said a lot
there. Um, is there anything you want me
to
>> No, I think that's um good. If we we can
start with Q&A. I can bring it around.
Um, since I have a wireless mic, you
have to stay with the wired mic. Um,
>> that's fine.
>> So, if I have any
first volunteers. Okay. Oh, and sorry,
uh, if you can please speak into the mic
because we have interpretation and
recording in both English and Spanish.
Um, hi, my name is Emily Flowers and we
just had a quick question for you. Um, I
think one of our main concerns is we um
have been very excited about welcoming
the students from Oak Springs um and
joining the two schools together and
being able to welcome them. And I feel
like that takes time and preparation and
we're like ready to go. So, we don't
want to like sit back and kind of just
like wait. Are we welcoming them? Are we
not welcoming them? And then I guess
another concern is I have heard that Oak
Springs is a much smaller school um even
when it will be complete. Um and the
woman that talked last time, I'm sorry
I'm forgetting who she was um but I know
she mentioned building school
camaraderie and just like um I guess
like togetherness and community. And if
we're combining to then separate again,
I don't feel like that's accomplishing
that. I feel like kids are going to be
building friendships, connecting with
teachers, connecting with everyone, and
then being divided again.
>> Yeah. No, great question. So, I'm I'm
gonna try to answer it in a way that I
think I heard it because I may not have
heard I want to make sure I'm answering
the right question the right way. Um, so
that's fantastic. Like, we want our
schools, we're all one big school
community. We want our schools to
welcome all of our students. I mean,
that's that's exactly how we should be
approaching it. Uh my recommendation to
the board is going to include Oak
Springs coming to Blackshere. Uh that
has to occur. There isn't the ability
for us to submit a turnaround plan to
the state of Texas that will be accepted
unless we do that. If that makes any
sense. I one of the questions that I've
been asked is could Blackshere go to Oak
Springs and the state of Texas would not
accept that um turnaround plan because
from their perspective you're taking a C
school and moving it to a school that
that hasn't met accountability. So
that's a big hard no for the state of
Texas, right? And we understand why. Um
now uh when you come together and just
to be clear, we've done this in the
past. We want you all to be a combined
school. We do not want two schools in
one two two programs in one school,
right? These are all our students. We
love them. We we we they this is one big
community. We we need to be that way. Um
the time and whatever future decision is
made is important because we want our
community to plan together for whatever
is next. But plan together I think is
the most important part. um we are not
going to ultimately end up with two
separate schools. I would not be able to
support, you know, Oak Springs coming to
Black Shear and then Oak Springs moving
back to their building. And one of the
main reasons is is that collectively in
parts of Austin, this is one of those
parts, we just have lots of empty seats.
And so in an effort to reduce the cost
that we have as a system and ensure that
every student gets what they need, we
have to kind of reduce the number of
empty seats we have collectively. Um
which is why uh at the end of this there
there really needs to be one school. You
know where it ends up and what it looks
like is really going to be end up based
on the feedback and conversations that
we have with you and the community
regarding the size. So um we have a
there are different sizes of elementary
schools that we have. Uh we have um a
traditional size which about 520
students. We have a larger size which is
about 620 and then we have like a jumbo.
I don't have another way to describe it
but this would be like a doss or maybe a
manaka where you're getting 700 800
kids.
um because of um where Oak Springs is um
they're uh tightened a little bit
because of um the way the site is
situated when you think about the back
side of the property. Um but we um feel
confident that the combined student
population will fit in that school. Uh
that is not a concern of ours. I've
tested it. Um I've overseen these
designs. I'm very confident it'll work.
uh one of the things that we would want
to do is to rethink the final design
components. So let's say at the end of
this there's an agreement. Okay, maybe
we want to go back after a couple years
because we still have to construct it,
right? It's not built yet. Um what does
it need to be? How does it need to be
different? The design scheme, you know,
the visual arts, uh and you know, the
all the work here. um what would need to
change at that facility to embrace that
learning experience? Like we could do
that. We have the ability to do it. Um
how do you honor the legacy of each
community? We've done that. You know,
we've done that with um Norman Sims.
Those are two separate campuses that
came together. They actually moved
together first and then they moved back
into the new home as one combined
school. Uh we had it with Mets and
Sanchez where it was a little bit
different where they moved together.
They moved back to the the new school
but they decided to keep the history of
Sanchez and didn't feel collectively
that the Mets history um needed to move
forward with it where Norman Sims it was
really clear like we wanted to have
both. So all of that is really worked
out with you all. What I would say is if
we were to move forward, you know,
depending on what it ended up being, um
I would um reissue contracts to the
designer and to the general contractor,
have them begin to engage with the
collective community to make the
refinements necessary so that it
welcomes the whole um and and that can
be that can look whatever it needs to
look like. Uh so so we have that
ability. It's it's unique. The other
thing that comes up is is what would
happen to the Blackshirt building
because I want to be honest like one of
the reasons that we moved this way
opposed to the other way or do a restart
was because the historic nature of
Blackshire, right? It's a historic
building like we we it's a historic site
historic for many reasons. Uh, and after
kind of spending time with community,
it's what I it's been shared with me is
there are lots of other things that
would be acceptable um that we've done
elsewhere in Austin. Like we've done an
early childhood center at Peas
Elementary School, which is another
historic building. Uh we can do kind of
all sorts of different programs. It
doesn't have to be one thing or the
other. Ideally, it's educational
purpose. Uh but it really depends on
what the community needs as a whole.
So hopefully that was answering some of
those questions. Um
>> and oh go ahead.
>> Yeah.
>> Hi again.
>> Hey.
>> So um I'm a parent to two former Black
Shear students. Um one's currently at
Macallum and one at Keeling. So couple
concerns. AISD had the underlying
accountability data for 2023 2024 a year
ago in August. This wasn't a surprise
and there could have been planning for
the last year based on the underlying
data without having the actual letter
grade for over a year. That's the first
thing.
>> Can I respond to that or you wait?
>> I'll wait. I'll wait. I'll wait.
>> Thank you. Um so you mentioned breaking
the account the accountability change is
the focus here and that's a surface
level problem because the root cause of
this is that students are not being
provided with consistently with highly
effective teaching with high quality
instructional materials and with high
expectations within a strong school
culture.
All of those are essential.
>> Oh yeah I agree. And then AISD, you in
particular have said that strategically
placing highly effective teachers in
schools that need them the most is not
what quote AISD does.
>> Uh so historic
>> cultural competence is considered to be
more important which what you told me
and that's a false choice because both
can be true. You can have a highly
effective teacher who is also culturally
competent. So my question,
regardless of where our students from
Oak Springs or Black Shere go, what are
you going to do to ensure that we have
highly effective teachers, high quality
instructional materials, and high expect
high expectations no matter what?
>> Yep. So um I I have different thoughts
on some of those comments. Um the first
thing I would say is uh it is not all
about accountability. Just to be clear,
I've never said that. I am saying that
if I do not break the accountability
chain, the district as a whole um may
introduce a risk that takes away local
control. So, it has to be part of the
consideration and has to be part of
this. If we ignore it, I promise all of
you and anybody that'll listen to me,
that puts us in a difficult situation
downstream. And you can look at Fort
Worth and what they didn't decide to do
two years ago that they would have
otherwise at this point wish they would
have done. I'm not going to allow us to
get there. The other thing I would say
is you asked about you know the
underlying data on 23 24 and 25. So I
want to recall I want everybody to
understand where we were in 2223 23 24
and 2425. Uh we came into a system
together right 2223 accountability. We
had three superintendents that year. I'm
not sure if people remember that. Uh we
had um our our staffing rate was around
84%. Now it's at 97%. We hired 26
principles that year. Uh this year we
hired five and I knew where all of them
went. Our attrition rate between title
one and title one schools was 22%. Now
it's 2 and a half%. And and I share this
because I want people to I want our
community to know that we have been
moving the system in a way that aligns
with who we are. At the time when 23 24
and 25 when we knew where we were, we
knew that we had work to do. We didn't
have students on grade level. We didn't
have aligned curriculum which is a big
issue. We're running 15 different
curriculum in Austin ISD. And who does
that hurt? It hurts students who have
high mobility rates. Students who are
moving because rent rent increases by
20%. And they're going from one school
to another, a different scope and
sequence, they go in and then we don't
have the ability to support them. So
that was a huge issue. So in 23, and I'm
saying this because I I I responded
because it seems as though we haven't
been doing a lot. We have been moving
this huge system and there's evidence
that it's working. So in 23 uh when we
first came together we uh went through a
procurement process. We um procured HMH
for K12. We for the first time in like
six years actually procured consumables.
So instead of having teachers having to
go to the to the photocopy room, we
actually had things that we could
distribute to our students. They could
use and they could touch and they could
work with. Uh we did that through this
spring semester. I mean sorry through
the summer. And then in 23 24 what were
we working through the TA agreed order
that thing that was going to take us
down. I don't remember I don't know if
we remember that but that was the thing
that was going to cause the state of
Texas to come and take us over. So we
had this huge issue that we were working
through. So we um then turned around our
ERP system which is the foundation like
platform that we used to manage all data
and then on top of that we build
multi-ter system support. So, for the
first time in a very long time, I can
tell you which students are on grade
level, which ones aren't across the
entire system. And two years ago, we
couldn't do that. And that's that's
that's wild, but we could not do that
two years ago. So, then you think about,
well, what do you what do you learn from
that information? Well, now you know,
you know, which students need tier two
or tier three interventions. You
understand um what you need to procure
as far as curriculum to ensure that uh
the um supports are there. We went after
a tax rate election to bring content
interventionists because we had schools
that had 40% of their students that
needed tier three interventions. Like
all these things were coming together
and we actually adopted curriculum h
high quality uh high quality
instructional materials. We've been
persistent in how we're using it and
we're tracking how it's being used. We
gave a presentation just a week and a
half ago that showed the adoption rate
and the use over the last three
semesters and it's gone from 55% to 82%.
And so what that's done is it's gotten
us to increase our early literacy um
outcomes and early numeracy outcomes in
a way they haven't moved for for years.
Um and so in 23 you had 30s. In 24 you
had 29. In 25 you have 23. Next year
you're going to have a fraction of that.
So I want to be really clear like we
have been working really really really
hard. You have to have an improved
climate and culture before you can take
anything on hard. I think we've done
that and you see that because staff are
it's hard work but um we're seeing like
movement into the system opposed to out
of the system which is very different
than three and a half years ago very
very different when we had a fear-based
culture. Uh so yes we had information
but if we would have acted in a way that
drove outcome movement only it wouldn't
have been who we are and that's what I
worry about and so like you can so you
can let's there have been models like
drill and kill model is something I
always said if you have a school and you
have middleofar data and it shows that
your students are not on grade level you
can do things to get the students to be
successful on the star test right like
you see that happen all throughout the
state of Texas. That is not who we are.
Like we want a sustained system that
does it the right way. So the grade is
important, but how you get the grade and
ensuring that sustained over time is
more important. And so we decided and
our board agreed that what we're going
to be doing is looking at like long-term
system improvement. And so because of
the lawsuits, because of the uncertainty
and what was going to be shared, because
of all the things that we were doing, we
knew that we were moving. we knew that
we needed to go um and the way that
things got released, you know, it it
created kind of pressures in the system,
but I don't want anybody here to think
that we haven't been working really
really hard and there's evidence that it
system is responding uh without a doubt.
Um and so regarding highly effective
teachers, that's a term the state uses.
I don't like to use that term. Um there
are lots of teachers that can be
identified as highly effective and
there's different ways to describe what
that looks like.
uh the state wants to make sure there's
correlation between uh you know your
teachers um observations and how they're
evaluated at the end of the year and
student outcomes in their classroom,
right? That's how they kind of align. I
will tell you that for a long time in
Austin ISD, we didn't even have a a way
to to align that and measure it. So, so
like I said, so, so, so now that we have
that um and we know how many teachers
have um the tenure, how many are TI TI
designated or nationally board
certified, I will tell you that years
ago I looked at certain verticals and
you had students have a first year
teacher three years in a row like you
cannot have that happen in our system.
But if you have attrition rates the way
that we did, you had staffing rates the
way we did, you're going to have it. And
so we've been combating that have all
the inputs and outputs in this in the
summit of data demonstrates that the
system is responding. Um could we have
done more? I I think that you could
always do more. Um do I believe that uh
in order to get the the ratings or if I
was kind of playing that game if we
would have if we would have aligned with
who we are? Probably not. Um so that's
the balance. I'm happy to share more,
but I just there's been a lot that this
school system has taken on. Um, and I'm
just really proud of like the teachers
and the principles because you don't see
turnover the way that you did before.
You don't. Um, and that's something I
think really that we should really be
proud of.
>> Okay, we have our next question.
>> Hi, I'm Laura Dela. I'm a current parent
at Black Shear. Um, I think I spoke last
Saturday, so nice to see you again.
>> Nice to see you.
>> But, um, I think we have great teachers
here in our school. Um I think that
[clears throat] they've demonstrated
that you know our schools rated C and
from the work by our teachers and our
students um that accountability chain
was already broken here.
>> Y
>> and so through their work um you know
this campus that's 134 plus years old
wasn't closed by the state. Um so
they're carrying forward that legacy. So
my question is when we have a campus
that's shown success in breaking that
chain,
why take students and move them here
where success has been demonstrated and
then move us all somewhere else
during that three-year period that we
have to maintain an accountability
level. How is incorporating additional
turmoil, additional change for the
students and the teachers and who
manages the new building process? Who's
going to be coordinating the education
of the students during the TAP? So,
we're moving the students here and
joining together. And I understand that
that's a requirement. Um, it's, you
know, we're we're very open to that and
we understand that that's a struggle for
everybody. It's going to be a change and
we're open to welcoming students. Um,
and we recognize that schools, all
schools that are closing are really
grieving and it's a real much more of a
struggle for them. But then to take, you
know, go through that one year
transition for everybody and then the
next year go through another huge
transition. That's two years into a
three-year accountability period. And
then you have one more year. So where
does that put us? um you know for the
students, for our teachers, and how does
that set everybody up for success so
that looking three and four and five
years out, we're not right back here.
>> Yeah. No, great question. So the first
thing I would say is UM
[applause]
so I want to be really clear. You say
you're saying you you like there's no
decision. There's no plan. Like that's
that's why we're in this process to talk
about what that looks like. I just want
to be really clear like I haven't, as
I've said before, I want to listen,
understand, and make an informed
decision. That's what this is about. So,
I don't want anybody to leave here
thinking that there's a decision being
made. This is really um based on
feedback that I've heard from others in
the same community. So, that and I'm I'm
committed to doing that. Um, as far as
uh other students coming into a school,
I I would I would say that there are
great things happening in all of our
schools. There just are. Um, and what we
think about whenever we have to go
through a disruption like this, where
can we keep the student body together,
right? It's always going to be
preferable to have one whole school
merge with another versus have a school
get split up. So, that's one thing. So,
two, the state of Texas, uh, you know,
strongly believes that if y'all been
doing great things, keep doing those
things, you know, and if you have a a
school that is working through the
accountability chain and is going to an
A or B or a C, kind of leave let them
keep doing their thing, right? Because
it's it's the same school system. It's
the same school district, same trustee,
same superintendent. Um but this school
um based on a variety of different
things in the past or maybe a lack of
resources you know elsewhere um just has
been able to be successful in this way
and so uh that gives um kind of more
flexibility to how that staffing plan
ultimately comes together. uh if it ends
up being if it wasn't the situation um
if it let's say that it was a a school
that's going through a restart, that's
when you really have pretty strict
requirements regarding the percent of
teachers in core instructional areas
that are highly effective. If you're
going from a a school that is um working
through the accountability chain and
going to an higher performing school,
which is what you have here, there's a a
lot more flexibility because the state
doesn't want to disrupt all the great
things that are already going on, right?
But we acknowledge that we need more
support because you have more students,
right? And they have different needs.
Um, and so that's how we're we're we're
tackling it. It's not um and the other
thing I'll say is transition is is
uh needs to be uh addressed. And the way
that you do it is by planning. Um, and
that's why you're never going to see me
make a decision in the spring semester.
I try to make it as early as possible. I
think clear is kind. Um, I cannot take
away planning time from our families and
from our staff. And so my hope is that,
you know, whatever we decide to do as a
community, we um create the time, bring
communities together, and then plan it
out. I have the frameworks and the
structures and things that we need to
consider, but the details of that should
be built out by you all um and and the
Oak Springs community and the collective
community. uh regarding transition
period time. I mean that school has
paused so the construction hasn't
progressed and by law I'm required to
execute the turnaround plan until the
chain is broken. So it's not like I
could you know start the plan and then
not complete the plan and move you back.
Like we'd have to really ensure that the
students had met accountability from the
state's perspective. the tap had been
executed and at that point, you know,
you can move um if we wanted to back to
a new the new school. What we don't want
to do is to not understand that because
if we're if we're going to move back,
then I want construction to continue,
right? If I if I don't, then I need to
stop, right? And then reallocate the
funds and continue on the path that we
are. So So that's how it would work. Um
so it wouldn't be I think a year in a
year. I think you have probably two in
one just because that project is slowed
down. We'd have to restart it back up
and then get back underway. Um and then
design correctly to en ensure that both
communities are welcome and see
themselves in the building. That's so
that's how it would work.
>> Okay, I'm going to come to you and then
you and you and then right back here.
So, and then I'll continue.
>> Yeah. Um, but just kind of piggybacking
on that question, right? So, what
consideration as we're talking about
like necessary disruption versus
additional disruption because that's
what I I think it makes a lot of sense
the part uh for the 2627 school year,
right, to have the schools consolidate
here. But what consideration is being
given? Um, and I think what I'd been
reading it was slated for the 27
or yeah 27 28
year that they would be looking at
moving back, but even two years out,
right? Um, what what consideration is
being given on that additional rup uh
disruption and how it will impact that
turnaround plan and has consideration
been given to that? And then my other
question is, and I'm so sorry, um, but
you know, a modern building is one type
of infrastructure that can help students
learn, but there's also the professional
and the community infrastructure
that's already in place here. So I guess
has has it is it being considered you
know the importance of that
infrastructure on the success of the
students and if a modern building um
actually merits
rebuilding that.
>> Yeah. So um
one of the reasons that
No, it's a great question.
Uh, one of the reasons that we are
modernized facilities, modernizing the
facilities is a couple. First is the
general operating expenses that we that
we have as a school system. Um, given
how old we are, I mean, we're just we're
just old. Things break all the time, you
know, and those improvements come out of
our general operating budget. Uh, so,
you know, in some years they spend 124
million on rental chillers, replacing
electric, like, you know, just things
that aren't capitalized. So they have to
come out of our operating budget. And so
in 2017 and 2022, we said, you know
what, instead of spending, you know, $12
million or a million dollars like, you
know, every single year depending on the
campus, let's really think through how
to modernize the space because if I can
um get rid of all the deferred
maintenance, right, then my cost per
year goes down. And that's the same the
same dollars that I'm using for teacher
salaries and for programs, the same
bucket of money. And so that was the
general philosophy. Um, and I also want
to be really clear that there are things
um that older schools just don't have.
And I I want to be really clear like
schools are so much more than a
building, right? It's you can have an
incredible school in a sea of portables.
That happens. That can be fine. But the
reality is over time there are other
things that you want to make sure you do
have. You want to make sure you have
light that goes deep into the building.
You want to make sure that the air
quality is at a certain level. You want
to make sure that safety and security
requirements meet the oblig the
expectations of the school system. So,
you know, security vestibules, lines of
sight, you know, like all the things
that that you would want to see in a in
a in a school at given the content
context we're in um is incorporated into
our designs now. And so when you think
about students and kind of what students
need um to be successful, we always
think about shelter, we think about
food, we think about lots of things, but
you know, if your HVAC system isn't
running, like it's really hard to learn.
If if this, you know, if water's not
running, this happens. You know, it's
it's really difficult. Uh but also, does
a student feel safe? And safety is
community, right? Like that's 95% of it.
Um but the building also contributes and
right wrong or indifferent you know with
116 buildings we do have instances every
single day that the chiefs and I mean
chief of police and our SRO's work
through and um over time you know in the
next 50 years right you want to get to a
place where the system as a whole is
just has the infrastructure to support
your students wholly in a way that they
couldn't have been supported 50 years
back because it's not n 2025 versus you
know 2050. It's the building from 19,
you know, like 1910 or whatever versus
where we're going. So that that's really
what it is more than anything else. It
doesn't mean that, you know, we can't
have incredible schools and old
buildings. It happens all the time. It
just means as a system um the goal
generally is to to move in this way.
Now, could you do a huge renovation and
do all these things? Sure. Um what it
really limits you is the um the
corridors, the widths of the building,
the setbacks, uh just the things that
you have now. Um but it doesn't mean
that one's better than the other. It's
just as a system if you continue to
operate really really old buildings
everywhere. It just it it really hammers
you. So that's that's just generally
speaking kind of what it looks like. Um
and then the disruption piece. I mean,
to picky back off what the um the person
in front of you said, uh I think that's
where we just have to work through it if
we go that way, right? I mean, that's
really what it comes down to. I'm not
going to present something that doesn't
work unless y'all's voice is in it.
Like, I'm just not going to do that.
Uh maybe you can clarify or help me
understand a slightly bigger picture
moment here of
>> so like consolidation started happening
because of the enormous budget deficit
>> and
in the process we're resolving tap like
performance plan. So here's my my actual
question is
>> okay
>> can you tell us how finishing one
building moving a school finishing that
building and then moving a school again
is cost effective
and
>> yeah sure
>> meets the goals that we're trying to
>> yeah so
>> achieve here
>> so um so so to be clear um there are so
many pressures in AISD right now like I
just y'all Well, I mean, just to be
honest, I have accountability pressure.
We have pressures from our response to
TA read order. We have budget
challenges. The federal government, the
way that that title 2, title three, and
title four dollars have been impacted
over the last year have caused me to
make very like challenging decisions
that impact our ability to support our
students, right? That's just your job.
>> I No.
No. I get that
>> but I don't I mean it's but for me it's
it's like I have to think about 50
years. I mean that is what we're trying
to do. We have to think in terms of 50
years. So when we talked about what
we're doing as a system I had to address
the accountability risk which we're
talking about here. I had to address the
surplus of seats which we have in this
area. I had to align feeder patterns
which has caused lots of frustration
throughout our community. But at the end
of the day you have aligned feeder
patterns in West Austin. You don't have
in East Austin. I have middle schools in
East that go to four or five high
schools. That doesn't happen at
Merkerson. Doesn't happen at O'Henry. It
doesn't happen at Gitzky. They go to one
high school. So if you don't fix that in
50 years or in 20 years or in 10 years,
you don't look back and realize all the
harm and disruption that's caused
because you had the opportunity to
address it. You didn't. The other thing
we had to make sure is program alignment
which doesn't really impact this area as
much but our our um district-wide um
dual language programs like they were
intended to serve emerging bilingual
students and the city has grown and
families have shifted and and now we
have schools that have 14 21 22 and 44%
emerging bilingual students is moving in
the wrong direction and by law 89th
legislature said that Matias school
districts you're going to have to ensure
that you have a certified teacher in
every classroom right Now, 12% of our
teachers are on alternative
certifications. And so, if I'm going to
have to get to a point where I have to
pull a teacher because I have emerging
bilingual students here that require a
teacher, where am I going to pull them
from? I'm going to pull them from the
program that has the teacher but does
not have the students. And so, that's
going to put those programs in a
difficult position in a year or two,
which is what I'm trying to do now is
position those programs to be
sustainable for years to come. And I
would say lastly, addressing our
transfer policy. So, I just want to
really clear those are the five things.
And if you did any one of them in
isolation, then you would not have the
same solution, right? Uh so I just
wanted to like put that out there. I
know Christina covered it, but for me
it's really really important we talk
about it. So how does it save um funds
over a period of time? Because you said
that's one of the things that
contributed to it, and it is, but it's
not the only thing. I just described
many others. Uh the a one-time
disruption in cost is different than
like cost in perpetuity, right? So
people will say, "Matias, go sell
properties, right, to to do to up offset
the budget." The reality of it all is I
can sell a property for $20 million and
there'll be a drop in the bucket. What
we need to do is to reduce our overall
cost because that cost is reoccurring
year over year over year. At the same
time, I need to pay teachers more. At
the same time, I need to put more money
into our students and and support them
and recognize that every student has a
different need. And so there will be a
disruption. It occurs whenever we merge
schools. that occurs when we build
schools there. This summer you are going
to see more movement of students than
the last 144 years because we're
building the 2022 bond program and you
have almost I think eight or nine
schools coming online. So they're going
they were out of school, they moved to a
portable village either on-site or
off-site and now they're moving back to
the new school. So this happens all the
time in Austin ISD. It happens all the
time. Um, but what we have to think
about is five years, 10 years, 20 years
because, you know, we are in the forever
business, but I cannot um I I cannot shy
away from a short-term disruption if it
ultimately stabilizes the district long
term. Uh, and and that's really what all
this is about. Um, so if you you know,
and I I will hear sometimes, Matias,
well, you may lose students because of
this change. And my argument is, okay,
well, how many students are not coming
to Austin ISD and are going to a
different school because they don't
think they have a strong neighborhood
school in their neighborhood, right? We
know those numbers. They're going to
charters or maybe they're going to a
different school all across town. Like,
why do they feel like they have to do
that? We should be able to provide the
resources so that that school is
supported and and becomes a strong,
thriving neighborhood school. They're
already strong, but for whatever reason,
based on decisions the district made in
years past, they haven't been able to
meet accountability. So, it's it um I I
know you're probably wanting a more
precise answer is like prove to me that
this is works and this doesn't work. You
know, I'm a systems person. I think
about the whole I have 70,000 students
um 116 campuses. You know, a lot of
things that are all kind of working
together, but at the end of the day, we
have schools that do not have the
resources that they need to be
successful. And I don't I don't have
enough to spread.
>> Can you boil it down? This is not a
costaving measure. the success of the
program.
>> I would say it's a stability of the
entire organization like all of these
cut together but some reduce costs some
require a slight increase in cost over a
short period of time but at the end of
the day the net is a reduction in cost
for sure because you have fewer empty
seats. We have 20,000 empty seats right
now. That's 3,000 seats larger than the
Moody Theater. Uh the Moody Center. I
haven't been to it, but that's, you
know, that's that's that's that's what
it is. So, it's it's a lot of seats, and
they're not all like in one area. And if
I and if I did only close schools that
had low numbers of students, then it
would all be in East Austin. And that's
what we're we're trying to avoid is is
that kind of like weight that one
community carries over the other.
>> Hi, my name
>> Oh, here. Sorry.
>> My name is Mark Coparo. I'm a parent of
two students here at Blackshere and uh
you seem extremely confident that the
new construction at Oak Springs can do
this. My question is why wasn't it part
of the initial plan and why did it occur
spontaneously at a community meeting I
think that was on a week night sometime
and second part of that question
was it
designed to prevent us from doing what
Maplewood did which would which is
effective because I feel like this
community could put out save black cheer
concerts and save black share signs and
I respectfully
you you know you're you're asserting
that this can be done but you've I've
not seen any evidence that this school
can maintain that the the new
construction can do this and again why
was it not if if you're so confident
that it can be done why was it not a
part of the initial draft plan
>> so I so the first thing I I would say is
you're I I I don't do that. Like I don't
try to overthink how a community is
going to respond. I mean, community
shows up how they want to show up and I
I love however a community show chooses
to show up, I'm going to be there. I
mean, that's just how I am. Um I don't
compare one school to another. Uh I I I
just that's just not who I am. Um now
talk about confidence. Um my confidence
is not that this could work, the
existing plan can work equally as well.
I want to be really clear like I I I
don't necessarily
um feel as though I'm trying to change
something that that I don't already have
confidence in. This plan came to be
because I felt very strongly that the
current plan could work and and so to so
I know you're about to shake your head,
but let me finish this comment. The the
feedback
>> confused about which plan you're talking
about, right? So the original plan
October October 3rd and then the 31st
which included Oak Springs moving to
Blackshere that was the plan that I feel
very confident in that plan. I feel like
it would work. I feel like it it it
would ultimately do many many incredible
things for this school community and
this school district. Period. And as I
said before like I am committed to
exploring any idea that comes up period.
And I can tell you precisely where this
idea came up. It came up when I was at
the um uh with Reverend Lans at the East
Side committee meeting, but I'm just
sharing with you
>> I I I mean,
>> you know, it was not
>> I'm just sharing with you where it came
from. I I I'm honestly telling you like
this happens throughout the city where
ideas come and I would say, "Okay, if
that's something the committee wants me
to explore, I will explore it and we
will go through it together." And that's
what this is about right now. This is me
doing exactly what I said I would do and
telling my board and telling our
community we're going to go through this
process. Um did I look at it the other
way? I I did. But the problem is is I
cannot move Black Shear into a um a
school that had historically not
performed right. So from a turnaround
perspective, right, it wouldn't work
that way. Could it work if both schools
were high performing and we just had to
do a consolidation? Yeah, it could
absolutely work. And so that that I
think coupled with the fact that I had
heard for a very long time that the
black shear um school historic in nature
building and everything else was
something that needed to be considered
allowed me to get comfortable with that
plan because it broke the accountability
chain. It reduced the number of seats in
the area and honored what I had heard
which was, you know, the Black Shear um
school is historic and it needs to be,
you know, um maybe supported or
evaluated in that way. They used to be a
consideration. That's how we ended up
there. And it wasn't until community
came out and told me Matias, think about
it this different way and that's what
we're doing now. So that's just the
honest truth. Um and so I don't know was
uh and so this is just about listening
and hearing and and then
>> well I do hope you're hearing that you
know
my family and my children.
>> Okay,
>> understood.
>> We have um one right here. I'll come
back here and then right over here and
then Okay.
Hi, thank you very much for being here
uh today, Matias. My name is Edna. I
have my husband and I have two kids here
at Blackshere. We are also very big fans
of public education and AISD as well. I
know that you are in a very difficult
position um and that your job is not
envied by anyone. So um I my com my
question is also somewhat of a comment
but something that I do want you to
address. Um much like Jennifer said at
the start of the meeting, we as a
community here in Black and I hope you
see the entire community here, including
our amazing teachers, our principal, uh
parents, supporters in the neighborhood
as well. Um we're here because we want
you to understand the community that we
have and it's not just um about uh the
building or things like that, right? We
want to welcome Oak Springs. We want
them to become a part of our community
um in hopes that you're right 5 10 15 20
years down the road that AISD is
successful and AISD especially in
neighborhoods that have been neglected
on the east side is successful right so
we want to continue that I do think that
um the your idea about short-term
disruptions versus long-term disruptions
I completely understand that as a
systems person myself right but I would
like you to consider um the disruption
that comes from in some ways moving a
community here, which we want. We want
them to stay here, and then moving
everyone back to a new building, what
the impact that has um in terms of
disruption for you have a transportation
plan that may have already been figured
out and then you have to reverse it in
another way and it might not serve
people within this community to go back
the other way. If you have a plan that
works and that has been working for one,
two, three years, you have teachers who
are in the classrooms that they're
known, teachers that are dedicated to
the students and community here. And to
lift that all back and then put it into
a new facility and a new building, I'm
not sure that that counts as a just a
short-term disruption. To me, it seems
like it would also be much more of a
longer term uh disruption. And so for me
at at least and I think I I some of the
other community members echo this as
well. We I understand consolidation. We
understand consolidation. We're
underenrolled. Kids don't have
resources. Teachers don't have re
resources. We need to consolidate in
order to to be able to do that. And I
highly believe in that and think it has
to be done. But I think it should also
be done in a thoughtful manner in terms
of not just short-term long-term
disruptions, but thinking about how
those actual disruptions where you say
this is a short-term run disruption that
will have a a better long-term impact.
thinking about the other way where is if
we don't have that disruption in the in
the first place even though it's a new
building and all these things are there
things we can do to minimize that
short-term disruption and still have
that long-term positive effect 15 20 30
years down the road
>> I mean
>> you know I I mean it was well said what
you and I appreciate you you know
commiserating with me on the all the
things that we're working through. Uh it
is real. Um you know, I love this city.
I love this school district. Uh we're
trying really hard to get it right.
Right. When when no one is doing us any
favors. Um is kind of what I feel like.
Uh so, you know, I think the my response
I guess generally is um you know, we
have we have evidence and you know, of
us being able to do pretty incredible
things well if we plan together and
execute. And I would say for me, you
know, I'm here precisely at this time in
Austin ISD to ensure that we execute in
a way that we haven't in the past. To
agree to order, MTSS, I mean, all the
things. Um, and we've seen lots of moves
happen in Austin ISD. And I think that's
why the idea didn't seem so foreign when
it was proposed to us, right? We've seen
huge elementary schools move off site.
You know, that happened at Brentwood.
They went to web. I've seen, you know,
two schools leave both schools and go to
another school combined and then move
back to the to the brand new school.
I've seen um just about every iteration
of it, you know, and and so I Yes, it's
a disruption. Is it something that we
can work through? I believe that we
could and I we've seen that occur over
the last couple years and it's happening
right now. I mean, we have schools that
are not at their home campus and will
not be for a couple years. Um and and we
just work through it. it's important
that we have our principal and we have
our staff like all buy into the plan.
But that's right, you have to agree on
the plan and you have to ensure that
it's executed with fidelity. Um, and so,
you know, I think it's a consideration.
Um, it is something that we definitely
take to to to heart. Um, but in some
cases we we just have to do it. Uh, and
we've demonstrated that we can do it.
And so that I will kind of go back to
the team and we'll talk about is this is
this different or something that we need
to do differently here if we go down
this path which again there's no
decision no recommendation. Um I'm happy
to explore that. Um but I just want to
be really honest like like there there
are there's one two I think there's four
schools right now that are not even on
their own home campus right and they're
they're far away and several of them
will be combining and coming back and
they're thriving you know so I I just
like it can be done. Um, I feel like it
it can be done. Um, maybe I need to
reassess if it can be done here. Um, but
you know, we have evidence that it can
be done,
>> right? And I don't doubt that it can be
done.
together
isn't necessarily the right thing.
>> That's fair.
>> Okay, we have another question.
>> Well, hello. My name is Martin Crey and
I'm uh also a parent of a child here and
um I like many of us in here. Um don't
envy your position. We thank you for
taking the time to come out and and
listen to us. Um Edna was very
articulate in what she said and um I'm
going to try not to be redundant but
maybe perhaps put a finer point on it.
Um, Blackshire as you see is a community
of uh faculty, staff, uh, you know,
educators, the staff that support them,
all the programming, and then of course
the parents themselves that both
support, um, the teachers and of course
our own our own kids. And I know there
was talk of the culture piece and um you
know of of this building as a building,
but um I'd like you to give
consideration to where this building is
located um and for how long it's been
here. There are people who are part of
the Black Share family who have been
part of this uh of this institution for
40 or 50 years. They live in this
neighborhood. They walk here. um they
have ties to local institutions that are
part of what makes this facility and
this school um what it is and and and
and and helps us to thrive the way the
programming is um supported of course at
the district level but also by um much
of um the local institutions nearby um
the historic university that's next door
that's a very welcoming um partner to
this school just take into consideration
the actual neighborhood context of this
historic building and location. Um and
and consider how these disruptions
um could impact not just the families
but the programming the entire um just
the feel of what makes Black Shear Black
Shear and Black Shear kids Black Shear
kids. So, um I don't know how else to or
how
more articulate I can play I I I I can
make the point, but um Black Shear's
historic nature is not just how long
it's been um in this particular spot,
but the fact that it is in this
particular spot.
[applause]
Hi, John Flowers. I'm uh my daughter is
in pre-K here at Blackshire. I've got
two questions, hopefully pretty easy
ones for you. Um they're for more short
term for the plan for next year. Um the
first one is the second d or I guess the
draft plan came out, official paperwork
basically had the attendance boundaries
getting adjusted in kind of two ways.
one from uh actual consolidations like
Oak Springs coming into us where we're
essentially getting the retired tenants
zone and also certain places switch
certain neighborhoods switching between
schools. Um the kind of postdraft update
that came out last week said a lot of
that was getting paused and we kind of
have both affecting us. We have
obviously the Oak Springs area coming
into Blackshire. We also have like areas
from Matthews and Zavala etc also coming
in. So is it is all of that is half of
that being caused and we're only getting
Oak Springs or we still getting other
areas as well? Yeah, it's a great
question. So, uh, what I've been doing
is working with the team and, uh,
looking at the boundary changes that are
absolutely necessary to be responsive to
the turnaround plans and the
programmatic moves. Whenever we did a
comprehensive, and we're still going to
do it, y'all, just to be clear, like
we're still going to go forward. Um,
that work is not stopping. uh but when
we did it comprehensively we created
kind of ranges and we said you know as a
healthy for a healthy system you want to
be between 85 and 95% utilized and so
there were lots of boundary changes and
those boundary changes for elementary
schools had to line up with middle
schools and line up with high schools to
ensure beater pattern alignment and so
um what I told the team and what I
instructed and what I what I reviewed
since uh are the changes required to
support the turnaround plan in this case
it's Oak Springs to Blackshere and that
is really the extent of the boundary
change for the vote that is being
completed on November 20th. Um, you
know, when we pick that work back up,
which we are going to do in very short
order, um, we're going to begin to uh
address all the other changes. Um, I I'm
not confident I can get it to December.
I know the trustes that have asked me
about that. Um, so it it'll likely be a
little bit longer. Uh but but that's the
kind of the extent of of the work and
and the reason we're able to do that is
because you know we were trying to
balance the entire system but if we make
some moves like this you may get to 96%
or 97% which is 2% higher than the
target rate. Um, but at the end of the
day, you know, that's based on reside
and you know the number of students that
transfer in, the number that transfer
out, the enrollment number, and then
after I review all of that, I'm very
confident that it it works given the
fact that even if we're over by 2%. Does
that make any sense? Uh, the other thing
that I will say is for our calculations,
we use um permanent infrastructure, not
portables. Right now, we have 440
portables in Austin ISD representing
over a million square feet. Uh our
newest portable is like 32 years old. We
have some that are 60 70 years old. Uh
they're meant to be short-term
solutions. And so for a short term um
I'm willing to use them to help ensure
that we have the capacity to make any of
these moves work without having to make
the other offsetting move work. Does
that make sense? Yeah. So it sounds like
only not the second half but the first
half went back to
>> Okay. I
>> that was only one question. You said a
couple of questions.
>> Uh yeah, the other one's hopefully
pretty easy. um the for the Oakidge
community that is coming over here. I
know it's obviously a much bigger effect
on sorry a much bigger effect on them.
Um but I know I've I've heard that a
large concentration of them live very
close to the school like within walking
distance and also don't really have
reliable transportation. Technically
we're within the 2-m boundary where
transportation doesn't have to be
provided. So I I think as a community we
probably push to provide transportation
for them to help account for that move.
>> Yeah. Well, and and uh so I appreciate
you saying that because uh that that is
one of the things that was shared
initially about, you know, why maybe the
combined school should end up there. Um
because of the student needs of the of
the population that is really close to
that school. Um and so we, you know, we
always think about like, you know, which
student is going to be adversely
impacted to a greater degree because of
their lived experience. Um and so that
that is really one of the things that
allowed me to continue to explore this
and really lead to this conversation
here. Uh but yes, we can absolutely add
transportation. We've already committed
to doing it. Um you know, for for the
swings for the move from Oak Springs to
Black Share, uh it's within the two
miles. Um but we certainly recognize uh
that we just, you know, we need to
provide more support and we can do that.
We have the ability to do so. I have the
authority to do so and we're doing it
and that's going to be in the plan.
>> Okay. I have five on deck. So, one, two,
three, four, five. So, I'll let
>> Hey, my name is Mo Buchell. We met out
back there. Sorry if this was addressed
before. I was uh trying to direct people
in the front.
>> Yeah, sorry. I was like I was like
rushing in. I was like, where's
>> Yeah, no, it's all good. Um uh so you
mentioned, and so forgive me if this was
addressed before I came in, but you
mentioned uh that, you know, obviously a
lot of this is because of an enrollment
crisis in the district, right? Um, and
uh, I'm curious if you've considered the
impact of closing a school like Black
Shear that has such like a great
reputation for
navigating like a lot of the uh, the
challenges and complexities that are
happening on the east side right now. I
mean, Black is a school that's really
stood out. It does great by its
students. When you close a school that's
doing that, does that threaten to
dissuade more parents from enrolling in
AISD? like is could that be kind of
actually uh counterproductive when
you're trying to attract people to the
school district?
>> Yeah. So, this is something
I've been now I've been in Austin ISC,
believe it or not, like seven and a half
years. Um been in this role now almost
three years, first year's interim. And
one of the things that I'm always um
kind of grappling with is how to
um extrapolate or arrive at numbers that
I can depend on for an assumption,
right? Because our trustees asked for it
like Matias, you know, if this happens,
what is going to be the impact to your
budget? Uh and my response and my
response to you is going to be um first,
we don't want any family to leave,
right? But we want families to do what's
best for their student. And I do believe
that, you know, Austin ISD provides the
best public education in in Austin,
period. And we have evidence of that as
especially given our scale. Like we we
do some really incredible things and we
have um depth and we have resources that
many other schools can't provide. And
and that is, you know, really important
that we protect that. Um will students
move? Will they leave? Uh I get this
sometimes and I'll I'll hear Matias, we
did a survey of our families and 60% are
going to leave. Um, and just to be
really honest, I've also received
surveys four years ago when we went
through similar changes. And I I know
that that wasn't what ultimately
happened. Um, and I also know that there
are lots of um times when community will
leave and then come back or actually go
back into the system when once there's a
break in the school in the um kind of
vertical team like let's say elementary
school breaks uh is consolidated and
perhaps they leave. But we have seen
that what really anchors our school our
school system is our high schools. And
lots of families end up coming back. And
so um we do uh account for it by way of
um of a sensitivity analysis on our
financials and say okay we lose x amount
of students here um what might that look
like? The counterposition, this is
something that I am really honest about,
is what would families do if you had
thriving schools that are high
performing in areas of Austin that
haven't had them? Because there are
parts of our city right now where many
of the students who reside choose to not
come to Austin ISD. And why is that?
Well, I mean, one of them is the reasons
is that the school is not identified as
high performing because a lot of
families, you know, they don't know what
we what I know or don't know how
beautiful the school is inside
necessarily or the great things
happening. They see this letter grade
and they make a decision and and
families are busy. Like, I understand
that. And so if we're able to actually
pull the resources to ensure that every
student gets what they need and we
already have evidence the system is
responding and your schools improve,
which that we're already improving. I
just gave stats about how we're
improving, then you would expect to get
a lot of them back. Like one of the
things that I would argue is Martin now
having access to Keeling, all the
students who are not choosing Martin, I
would expect that to increase because
now they have access to Keeling. And
that's one of the things that we're
doing as part of this plan. So, as a
whole, when 70,000 students, there's
there's students that choose to leave,
there's students that choose to come. I
want to make sure that we do everything
possible to attract families. Um, so
yes, we do talk about it. We do localize
it and we say, "Okay, what could the
impact be here?" Um, but as a whole, I'm
not able to support everything. That's
the honest truth. Um, but if we do it
well, we should have strong neighborhood
schools. And if we do that, then we
would see an increase in students. Um,
again
the challenges that we have like we lost
2,000 students over 2,000 students this
year. Had nothing to do with
performance. It had nothing to do with
gentrification. It had to do with
immigration. We lost two over 200
students. They're in they're in the
Rberg area. Like that entire student we
lost families who did not immigrate to
Austin and we lost some that decided to
leave. That is a huge huge number and
like largely is greater than anything we
would see as part of these moves. So, so
there are things happening that I'm
having that we are having to work
through that um or you we couldn't have
I would if you would have told me last
year that we would have seen that
there's no way I would have believed it.
Uh not to that degree but something
changes at the federal level,
immigration changes or the response from
the federal government changes and then
you see this impact. So, it it it's a
long-winded answer to say we model it,
we track it. Um, when I hear things,
sometimes they work. I sometimes they do
come to fruition, sometimes they don't.
Um, but if we can improve our entire
system, my hope is that more families in
Austin select Austin ISD. Um, so I don't
know that was but that's that's just
like the honest truth.
>> Okay. I I do want to do a quick time
check. We are about 14 minutes from the
end of the meeting, but because we did
start a little bit late, I'm going to
add like 10 minutes on the back end if
that's okay with you.
So, um, I'll come to you and then have
>> I'll try to be quick. First, I'd like to
invite you to our 135th anniversary that
is happening in February at the school.
We're very excited.
>> Please come, please bring your staff and
help us celebrate the legacy of the
school. And I'd like to channel onto his
comment about the place-based identity
of this campus. We are right next to our
H.B.CU. We have amazing teachers here in
these halls who've graduated from there.
We are also right next to Keeling. I'm
so glad you brought that up. We have
little brothers and little sisters here
at the school. The middle schoolers come
down and they get their siblings so that
working families can keep working and
those siblings can help take those
younger kids home. Third, we're right
next to Carver Library, and that is a
really, really important third space for
our community where students can go
without their parents who are working.
We are working-class neighborhood. So,
please take into account that placebased
identity of our school. And then second,
I'm going to say we've been waiting with
baited breath and trying to be kind. We
have been told to not complain, but
we're seeing that the schools who are
complaining are getting your ear. We are
seeing that the schools who raise money,
the schools who protest, the schools
that have money are going to stay open
and our school, we don't have the time
to make this change. We are welcoming
them with open arms for this turnaround
plan and we need the time. Our teachers
need to get ready. We need those funds.
We need plans in place and we will be
successful with that turnaround plan
because I believe in our leadership. I
believe in our teachers and I believe in
our community. But we can't do it if you
keep changing the script on us. It's not
going to happen.
>> Yeah. So
um I want to be really clear like that's
not how this works. I I that's not who I
am. Um just not uh there are lots of
voices all over the city of Austin.
There's our uh our board and I are very
committed to being like true to who we
are, our north star and and just be
diligent about the work because on Mon
on Friday when we upload our documents,
you're going to see closures, 10
closures that are very much still have
communities advocating. And so just I
just be really really clear like that's
not part of this, not what this is. um
when we when I decided to slow it down,
it's because I am 100% committed to
doing exactly what we're doing here.
Like I I need to listen and I need to
ensure that every idea is thoroughly
vetted. And when it comes to turnaround
plans, there are limitations because the
state of Texas, the requirements, how
close I've been to them, when it comes
to programmatic moves, the um the
foundation of the why is very clear,
like you know, all of those things are
able to progress. The the ones that were
very difficult were the countless
boundary changes uh and the like number
of committee meetings that we've had to
get that right and the balance
enrollment. like those are those are
just different types of um factors
contributing to those closures and so
you know there are three schools not all
of them have the same type of kind of
voice maybe is the way that you know so
I want to be really clear that's not who
the board is that's not who I am um if
if there needs to be a conversation
about you know all the things that I can
share with anybody everywhere about how
we are staying true I'm happy to have
that conversation but I'm I'm not going
to allow like that to even creep in
because that's just not who we are like
we're just not that we're not that
board. We're not that administration.
Um, you know, and uh I don't know what
else to say. Like that's just not what
this is. Um I I want to do a good job. I
want to make sure I'm listening to
community voice. Uh this could this
could be done so many different ways. I
mean it's it's done in other parts of
the state very very differently. Um I
love this school district. I I love our
community. I'm going to be here if
you're here. Um and I want to listen. I
want to improve and I want to refine.
And at any point if I think that the
voice is not getting in in the way that
I need it to, then I'm going to slow it
down. And that's what this is. But the
work's going to continue. There will be
additional consolidations. There will be
boundary changes. I'm not going to leave
my time here as a superintendent without
having a line feeder patterns in Austin.
That is the thing at the end of the day,
if we get that right, you look back in
20 years, 50 years, it will have a huge
impact in the city. Um, and I never
would have thought we'd be able to
tackle it. I mean, I just wouldn't. So,
anyway, just wanted to share that.
>> Okay.
All right. Uh, my name is Sherwin Patton
and uh, I debated on whether I was going
to ask a question or not, but I I wanted
to share a little bit of something. So,
I grew up in this community and still
live in this community.
My mother taught at Blackshere. My
mother went to Blackshere.
My mother went to Houston Tillerson.
graduated from Houston Tillis. So did my
father.
And so the reason why my mother taught
at Blackshire at one point in time was
because there was no other option until
schools were integrated
in which she was able to teach at other
schools after that. And so after that
she taught over at Lee Elementary
Schools once schools were integrated.
But we still lived over here in East
Austin.
My grandfather bought that property that
I now live on in 1930.
When he bought that property in 1930, my
father passed away and uh you know a few
years back and the the whole community
decided that they were going to do a
mural. I think it was led by Caitlyn and
some others. And there's a mural of my
father and some other people who lived
in that community that's still there now
as an educator in this community. What
my mother did was she made sure that
every child that lived in this community
had an option. They had an alternative
to everything else that was going on
around them. So she tutor
and she looked out for all the children
in the community.
So now what I do is I chase the children
who are in this community and make sure
that they all have options and I give
them the support that they need. And
that's what my organization does because
I'm living out what I saw my parents do,
not because they had a choice, because
they had to. And so when I look at the
community, you know, I I'm I'm glad to
see um the the community the way that it
is now that I get the chance to meet all
these new people, but it looks very
different
from when I was a child.
It looks very different now. Thanks to
um the fact that I have some great
neighbors, our end of the block is very
different than every block in this area
because we kind of where they hang out
and they they schedule stuff and they
invite me and I show up sometime.
But I say all that to say, um I spend a
lot of time down at Oak Springs because
I'm chasing the children. And I
understand um from looking in the room
that that the demographics has shifted a
little bit. And so I'm running after the
children because I'm trying to make sure
that they have the same types of options
that were afforded to me because my
mother and others sacrificed.
And so when we talk about um the
consolidation,
I I don't want it to be this us versus
them that we're talking about. This is
really all of us as East Austin coming
together because that's what East Austin
was all about. It was about us as a as a
people trying to survive and trying to
make sure that we did better than
survive that we could actually have a
chance to succeed. And some of the best
and brightest have come out of this
community. And so, uh, with that being
said, I I think that one of the most
important things, and here comes my
question.
It is for us to have
information about one another, not based
upon what we're hearing,
but building relationships because I
feel like we we may make some decisions
in a vacuum if you're not careful. If
we're not careful, we'll make a decision
without being informed because we won't
know the people who are directly
impacted. And I'm not talking about uh
just people at Oak Springs. I'm talking
about people in this community. And so
what I would like to propose and like to
ask um uh Superintendent
and thank you for having all of these
meetings. Is it possible for us to have
a gathering, a few gatherings of Oak
Springs and Black Shore community so
that we can actually sit down, learn to
know each other, talk and come up with a
solution for East Austin because this is
not a decision about what's going on
further east or over here because it was
never like that in this community. It
was always about East Austin and East
Austin has a rich history of having to
stick together. And so we cannot have a
us versus them dichotomy because if we
do it will not look like the East Austin
that we're saying that we're celebrating
right now. It will not look like that.
I'm telling you, Houston Tillerson is
across the street and Houston Tillerson
is trying to reach this entire community
and even beyond. and they're trying to
make a a path for success for primarily
black and brown students.
And what we're talking about right now
is a group of black and brown students
who will feel like they're being
displaced because they were promised
something. They were promised something
new and they rarely get anything new.
And so what I'm saying is that we just
need to find out how we can come
together and listen to everybody's
voice. And my my my question for you is
would you help us to provide a would you
help and provide a space for that to
happen and then come in and listen to
that group together and if are we as a
community willing to do that because if
we don't I'm telling you what will
happen is it'll feel like something done
to a group of people because I'm
listening. I live on this end of the
block but I'm frequently on that end of
the block. I grew up on this end of the
block. This is all I knew was this end
of the block. But I hang out a lot on
the other end of the block. And I'm
saying that if there's not a
conversation, what it's going to feel
like is something being done to people
versus something being done with people.
So,
Superintendent, back to your my
question. [clears throat] Will you will
you create a space where we can all come
together?
[applause]
>> Yeah. So, um, of course, you know, I I
think, uh, you know, like I'm committed
to to ensuring community comes together
to inform, you know, what what is the
best solution. Um, but I'm always going
to be really honest about what I can and
can't do, right? And we've had that
conversation. I've had lots of
conversations in the community about,
you know, could we do this, could we do
that, could we do that? And I'll be
honest, like, these are things I can't
support, but these are things that I
can, and here are the reasons why. Uh so
absolutely I I welcome the opportunity
to bring community together and provide
a space or or do what I can to
facilitate um you know and and and I'm
I'm happy to to participate and and I
want to be really clear like the vote
that's coming up is about like step one
a right it's it's truly being responsive
to turnaround plan. Um there may be
expectations um you know about what
included, what's not included, but it's
really about you know breaking the
turnaround plan. I mean creating the
turnaround plan and having us break the
accountability chain which does include
Oak Springs coming to Black. Um the
steps after I think there's plenty of
there's opportunity to have that
conversation together.
>> Okay.
>> Um I don't so much have a question but I
told my kid that I would just let you
know this so I'm going to do that.
>> Oh awesome. Uh we're new to Blackshere
this year. We've been in this community
exactly 12 weeks. Uh due to various
circumstances, my kid has this is his
third school. Um when he walked in this
building the very first time, the way he
lit up was unparalleled.
There is life in these walls and it's
not something that can be replaced or
rebuilt
somewhere else without mass amounts of
effort and togetherness. And even then,
I don't know. But my son wants you to
know that this building, the literal
building, the people in it, the walls,
the art on the walls, all of it makes
him feel safe. and he has never left
another school that he's been at more
excited or more engaged or more ready to
come back tomorrow. And that's it.
>> What you want? What you want? Thanks for
sharing that.
>> Hi, I'm Abby Burnham. Um, my daughter is
in prek here. My older two children are
at Zavala. My oldest was at Brook
Elementary um which closed when he was
in prek4. I am a teacher at Macllum High
School. I'm a former board um education
Austin board member. We've sat meetings
together and I just want to I you know I
heard I keep hearing empty seats, empty
seats. I've heard all about empty seats
for all of my children's education now
for all of the east side communities.
And I just have a couple of observations
and maybe not so much questions, but um
one is that you talked earlier about how
the kids come back to us in high school.
They tend to come back to us in high
school. Those empty seats return at the
high school level. They all fall into
place. But I have run a little social
experiment in my household this year
because again, my daughter is in preK4
here. And we chose this school um
because partially of the great advocacy
of Miss Bell, but because Zavala doesn't
have afterchool care. So when Brook was
closed and we were, you know, absorbed
into a new community and welcomed with
opened arms and told that afterchool
care would be coming to the east side,
it did not. And we had a four-year-old
who could not stay at Zavala because she
did not have after school care. And so
we have these communities and these
beautiful programs and all of these
things in place, but if we don't recruit
them at the early levels, if we don't
look at those empty seats starting in
preK3, preK4, then we are doing a
disservice to the enrollment in our
school district, which then causes these
fun financial problems. And so there
there is so much beautiful
community that happens here. And we've
heard all night about community. I've
seen two wonderful communities and and
I'm not going to, you know, I I can tell
you that my daughter will be staying at
Black Shear for the rest of her
elementary school education, even though
I will be routing kids to all different
schools on the east side because she is
a part of this community already. And
so, not only does AISTD need to do
better with engaging with families to
stay within their communities, to build
within their communities, to stop taking
their students across district to other
communities to start their education
because they'll stay there. But that's
going to help us build our enrollment
and fill those empty seats. And if we're
not looking at it at those earliest ages
when kids fall in love with schools and
fall in love with who they're around,
then we're really missing out on a core
part of our population.
And that is that is I I wish that that
you know I know that they're coming back
at high school, but I think we really
need to look at it from that early age.
>> Yeah. No, no. So, just to be clear, um
and I very much appreciate that comment.
Uh I I our prek program, our our
elementary schools, you know, they we
have such strong programming, you know,
in many areas. It's one of the anchors.
But we see the biggest disruption is
rising sixth graders, fifth to six, just
a kind of funky time. um you know
students you know our middle schools we
haven't quite figured out how to how to
support our middle schools in a way um
that is balanced and ensures that our
students get what they need one year
transitioning in one year transitioning
out so two things are happening I I yes
to the um ensuring that students move
into the system because we've found that
once they find a loving welcoming school
prek prek 3 pre-K4 and continue on like
we keep them they stay with us so
there's a lot of work to be done there I
don't disagree uh We revamped our um
enrollment uh platform. We're try we
have to get organized and do it in a way
that we haven't done in the past. Um I
will say that one of the things we
struggled with and this is like a kind
of a larger conversation for the last
three years. It's been urgent urgent
urgent urgent urgent like like the work
around the important um and the things
that are truly going to sustain us uh
has has been hard to execute because all
these huge things you know TA greeted
order you know budget you know we think
about like the the work around um
accountability like these are consuming
massive resources and it's all the same
people there like there no more people
like in that doing this work it's all
our principles and executive directors
and myself and our teams So that is
exactly where we want to go and I agree
with you. But I also want to say that
you can it's the the the the denominator
the total number of students in Austin
has shifted. Uh so yes we the capture
and the number of students can increase
but the sheer number of students that
are in Austin has changed. We have more
density but the density that we're
seeing is you know studios. It's
onebedroom condominiums. you know,
you're not seeing lots of three-bedroom
and two-bedroom uh units come online,
and that's really where you see the the
student yield, and you're not seeing in
places that are affordable. You know,
that's just not happening. And so, uh
the reality is that you see charters
closing, you see lots of or you you've
seen closures in other surrounding
school districts that have lots of
wealth. Um it is truly a function of
just affordability, but we need to do a
better job of capturing and supporting
our students who live here now. And I
and I agree that we're not doing as good
a job as we could. It is an area of
focus for me. It's an area of of intense
focus. I would say moving forward. Um I
would say the reason I haven't been able
to contribute all a lot of time and
energy into that space is because of
like literally what we've been working
through like for the last 24 to 36
months. It's been brutal.
>> Um but yeah, that's that's what we're
doing. Um and and the goal is to like do
these hard things but do them together.
You know, I I got to keep us together.
That's like my number one focus. It is
hard. These changes are hard. Um, but
we're an incredible school district and
we're doing incredible things and I will
not allow us to be Fort Worth. Like
that's not happening. Um, so you know, I
appreciate that comment and you know,
thanks for driving all over town. I
>> I know what that's like. It's brutal.
>> Okay. Well, uh, we do have our
interpreters that are kind of winding
down, so I want to be sure we get one of
our Spanish speakers who wants to ask a
question.
Oh yeah.
What's that?
Good evening, Matias. I I am a custodian
here. I've been here for nine years and
we are a family. All the kids here know
me and we are very proud to be a family
here and everything that I hear from all
the parents here is that we want to keep
being a family and being a community.
>> Yeah. No, that's
Uh, gracias. I mean, so, so, um,
I, for those of you that know me,
I will say and I will continue to say
that every single person in Austin ISD
contributes to the educational
experience of our students. And um you
know I I would say that our custodians,
our bus drivers, our food service
workers are like the foundation of our
school system. You know, you keep our
students safe and have eyes and know
them in a way that very few do honestly,
especially at our bigger schools. Our
food service workers sometimes see 50
60% of the student population and no
other educator does that. and our bus
drivers welcome our students, you know,
when they may have had a really
difficult day or night. And and so I
just want you to know like what you're
doing here at Blackshere
at Black is exactly what we want. We
love you. I'm so happy that you're with
us. Um you are part of what makes
Blackure a family. Uh and and just so
thank you. Thank you. That's exactly
what we want.
>> [applause]
>> Hi, I'm Rachel. I have two kids here at
Black Shear. I really appreciate you
taking the time to talk with us. I um I
appreciate the work that the district
has done. We we've been following along.
Um the the plan we saw October 3rd um
was holistic and it was ambitious and I
think we all are on board with those
goals. Um, I think that fast and
decisive action is a huge selling point.
I know it makes it harder. It makes it
harder for everyone to feel like they've
had a voice, but it's change is painful.
We want to get it done fast, right? And
and so I think a lot of the anxiety
you're hearing from us around the
possibility of a few years down the line
um moving campuses is based on wanting
to embrace our new community and move
forward. Um and you know, you talked
about some of these other campuses
moving back and forth and we know it's
doable. It it's not ideal. Um, and we
know some of our families here are here
because they didn't want to put their
kids through going to Mets and Sanchez
and um, back and forth. Um, and and so
it really, you know, we've we've been
very focused on uh, getting more
families, right? We we we want a bigger
school. Um and uh I I think every you
know year if not every month that that
people have that uncertainty
it it makes them choose something else
right it makes them choose where they
know their kid can stay. Um so I think
that's that's one um thing that we feel
really strongly about is like we want
especially with the tap right it's a
challenge we are very uh optimistic and
confident in our teachers and our
leadership team
>> um about our ability to succeed but we
really think that that that cloud
overhanging of like a future move would
really impede that success.
>> Um you can tell
like this school is old. It's but it's
wellmaintained. Miss Bell takes care of
us. You see the beautiful mural behind
you. That's an investment from the
community in
>> in our campus. You walk past the school
stage in our in our playground. These
are the investments, you know, um that
the community has put into the school
and they're not easily moved. Um
and um
the you know one one thing that I really
appreciate about the original plan is
how holistic it was.
And if if the decision if if Oak Springs
location was the historic campus that
didn't need a turnaround plan when you
were when you were making that holistic
plan, it would look different. And so
it's really hard to think about would
this would the black share moving to Oak
Springs fit into that be the plan if
that was your starting point, right? Uh
for example, the the campus um rebuild,
as I understand it, the the target
enrollment was like 375, which is not
the same as what you said a standard
elementary school campus. So when we
talk about operating efficient schools,
they're a little bit bigger. um and uh
and our arts programming, you know, we
we we have the space for that. Um and
and that's really important to our
community and it's been really
successful in helping us be a thriving
campus on the east side that's been
attracting and keeping people in the
district and even drawing people from
other districts. Um so I guess that's
not all a question, but I I wanted to um
thank you really for the work. We
appreciate you taking the time to talk
with us. We appreciate you listening to
Oak Springs and I want you to know that
our community is not only excited to
welcome Oak Springs, like we're
actively having WhatsApp conversations
about can we move our pickup soccer game
and like meet new friends, right? And
like start building those relationships.
So, um, thank you
[applause]
me again.
I do have a a comment because I'm
looking at
a TEA score and so I'm looking at 23 for
black.
for uh relative performance. Uh the
school got a C for closing the gap. It
got an F.
Let's see. What's the other one?
For
reliable performance, econom
economically disadvantage. And this was
for 23 as well. There was an F for
closing the gap. There was a D.
Okay.
Uh for Oh, I may have said the same
thing for um Okay, let me go to 25. So,
I'm sorry you all.
I thought I had it in order.
>> Do you want principal to answer?
>> No, I need you to answer. I don't need
>> No, no, not answer. Like get the numbers
so you don't have to fill them up. No, I
haven't. Uh, okay. And so for 25, the
relative performing for economically
disadvantaged was a D. And for closing
the gap was a D.
And so my question is because I let me
preface this first. First of all, I
attended Oak Springs to third grade
because it went from kinder to three.
Uh we stayed in Glenn Oak which was
under which is underneath Pleasant
Valley the bridge in that area with
urban rem renewal we moved on Angelina
and so I was here at Blackshire for two
years and so you're right there's a lot
of history at that school because not
only did I attend Blackshire so did my
mother and so did my grandmother when it
was Gregory town school. So, there's a
lot of history here. And my grandmother
was born in 1899. Okay. So, there's a
lot of history here. The reason I read
the the scores or the the grade is
because we're bringing Oak Springs over
and so we know that their grades for
economically disadvantaged is probably
similar to Blackshirt. So my question is
how because I'm having a hard time
trying to see how we are really trying
to
uh lift up
academics for student. I I'm I'm really
trying to grasp it because I honestly
believe you have a good heart. I really
do. I believe you're a good person. I
believe you mean well. However, I'm just
not getting that peace. So you can bring
them over.
They're going to uh consolidate with
what's here right now.
And the resources are going to do what?
Because I don't expect the school to go
from a C to an F. I don't expect it to
go from a C to a D. It can go from a C
to a B. It can go from a C to an A. But
it cannot decline. And then I have one
more thing because Bernardet
Webb and Dolby did a restart. Could you
not do a restart with Oak Springs
because you don't know as of yet what
their score is going to be? You could do
a restart as well.
Yeah. So, um,
so start with the last question first.
Um
so the
there are multiple things that we're
having to address at the same time and
Mr. Bradley, we've talked, you've
shared, we've had conversations around,
you know, accountability, seats, feeder
pattern alignment. I mean, you know,
transfer policies, like all the things.
The reality of it all is that there are
empty seats in this area. Um, and could
you restart uh Oak Springs? You could.
uh a restart uh for those who who don't
know, I think maybe I said in the
beginning is you turn over the principal
most likely because the principal has to
have demonstrated the ability to um move
a school from a a D to a a B or an F to
a C. Um the educators uh have to be 60%
uh highly effective. Again, that's a
state term, not Matias's term. Uh and
that includes uh elements of an ACE
model. So ACE is really what they refer
to now as a restart. The state changed
the kind of the note the verbiage that
they use. And so you want to have
typically three years of experience.
your outcomes have to be correlated to
uh your um performance or be TIA
designated or be a board a nationally
board certified teacher which means that
all the other staff um you know would
have we'd have to evaluate who's there
now see who could stay because the state
won't allow us to submit a plan that
doesn't meet that criteria and then we
would have to hire staff that met that
criteria and place them in Oak Springs.
Um and so could that be done? it could
be done. Uh the the challenge that we
have is, you know, when we look at
comprehensive plans, which is what we're
trying to do as a school system, you
still have excess seats. And so in the
event where you can solve multiple
challenges with with a solution, we we
aim to do that. Um and so you can
restart it, but you would still have the
same number of seats met across this
area. And again, right now, I can't
afford, we can't afford to give every
student what they need. And so, we're
trying to find like where can we find
these efficiencies so that over time we
can get there. Um, so as far as like
academic performance,
um, you know, there are lots of things
that contribute to a school's
accountability rating. Uh, y'all know
that it changed in 22 to 23. We saw
significant shift. We saw shifts here in
22 23. There's a huge downward shift.
We've seen 20 point swings in some areas
because of how this assessment just
changed. Um we had I forgot how many um
B schools that went to Fs, but I think
it was 16. Uh so there's a lot of
movement. So 23, 24, and 25 when you
think about what we're going to do.
Well, first uh well, we're going to
really look and make sure that all the
students have the resources they need.
Um you know, we make sure we're going to
add content interventionists. We're
going to add instructional coaches. Uh,
one of the things that we're also likely
be doing is adding an assistant
principal. Um, you know, when you bring
the student populations together, you
need to provide more support. Uh,
assistant principles typically are the
um kind of the partner to the principal
who's overseeing uh special education,
making sure our ARS and IEPs. So, we're
providing more support. We then look at
the school as a whole and work with each
school community and say, what do we
need to add as far as wraparound
services? We know that students in parts
of Austin need more, not just what's in
the classroom. I think there was a
comment around after school care. Um, we
make those adjustments. So, we have a
framework for all of it. We've allocated
funds for all of it. Um, the rigor, you
know, the way that we assess um and
track performance. Uh, so assessments
throughout the year. Uh, making sure
that we're very clear and that we see
the rigor in the classroom because at
the end of the day, we have to have high
expectations for our students. Doesn't
matter the color of your skin. You have
to have high expectations and the rigor
better match. Um I can tell you that
I've dissected schools in Austin ISD and
I look at and that they'll tell me
Matias we're going to get a C. Matas
we're going to get a C. And I look into
the data and I realize um once I get
into it that the rigor for campus A
versus campus B which is reflected in
the in the material that the students
are completing is very different. Very
different. And so that type of um
autonomy hurts us because you get to a
place where you are bringing the
expectation down to meet the students
ability instead of doing what's required
as far as interventions and the supports
to meet the rigor that we have to have.
So that's a big point of frustration for
me. It's a big really point of
disappointment for me like managing the
school system. We've been here for a
long time but we've adapted bad habits
in some cases. The problem is is that
whenever you create that baseline
foundation, the argument against it is
that you're taking away autonomy from a
school because autonomy is something
that lots of schools like to have. Um,
so we are building off the great things
that are already happening here at Black
Shear, providing additional supports,
working with both school communities,
working with the principal to ensure
what is the academic plan going to be
specifically to welcome those students.
And then we've committed budget items to
ensure that we actually resources and
get it done. um it'll move. Um there is
no doubt in my mind. I do expect it to
increase. Um I'm not going to be part of
a system that is not moving us in the
right direction. Uh so that's how we
would do it. And and all of that's kind
of laid out. The other thing um that's
been really helpful for us is we've
actually partnered um with uh a
technical partner and we've created
lighouses uh and observation um schools.
And so what this is is we as a school
district over the last year have changed
our approach uh in how we support
instruction. Our principles need to be
the academic leaders in the school,
right? that what was happening in years
past and I'm not I don't want to belabor
this but we would take our teachers and
we take them all to central office or we
would take them to a place and we
provide professional development and
then they would go and they would
instruct and they would you know align
their instruction with the curriculum
but what wasn't happening was the
coaching kind of in real time because
the principal wasn't always getting that
same professional development and
support and um that created a huge dis
like impact in our system. So now uh as
your principal can tell you is that we
have been really intentional in ensuring
that our principles are the
instructional leaders of their campus.
So when they're observing, when they're
having conversations, they're always
thinking about what can I do to ensure
that this student gets what they need to
be successful. Um and that's something
we flipped on its head. It wasn't like
that two years ago. It is a complete
shift and it's working. It's working
very very well. Uh so that's why it's
really important that um we all come
together with the leadership here and
and build that plan together. Uh but
again we we have tools. Oh the so back
sorry I'm digressing back to the
lighthouse and observate in um and
laboratory lab school. So what we're
doing here is we're having one school um
be the lighthouse school and then have
six schools around it and we do
instructional rounds where we go and
observe um and it's not staff it's
principles. we get principles together
and say, "Hey, what is happening in this
school? Uh let's go have a conversation.
Let's talk about what we saw, what we
didn't see. Let's break it down and then
let's kind of go back to our own schools
and then come back in that sharing model
throughout the year." It's proven to be
very successful. That's why you're
seeing early literacy and early numeracy
numbers move the way that they are and
they're moving quicker in areas where we
have higher numbers of students who've
been historically reserved. Um because I
my argument is that you can have high
performing schools but they're
performing in spite of the instruction
that's occurring in the classroom. Uh
and you see that in parts of town
because the students already come in on
grade level, right? Um you know what we
need to demonstrate is growth that our
students are are getting on grade level
and growing no matter if they're coming
in on grade level and they need to go
grow beyond it or they're coming below
need to get back on and then grow. So so
our our approach is very very different
than what we've been doing the last two
years. Um actually last three years. uh
the principles and you know uh Jennifer
Pace and others can speak to it probably
better than I can but um we're doing a
lot differently and that's what I expect
to happen here. We'll break it for sure.
I'm very confident we'll break it.
People ask me all the time, do you feel
like this plan will derisk the school
district? I think it would for a variety
of reasons whether it's budget
accountability
allow us to allocate more resources,
special education. Um so I am confident
that it would move us in the right
direction holistically. still got to do
the boundaries which we're going to get
done and it's not going to take forever.
I promise you like that is gonna happen.
So anyway, thank you Cheryl.
>> Well, we are uh quite a bit over time
and I want to respect everyone so y'all
can get to times and dinners and all of
the things. Um so I don't know if uh you
have anything else. You've you've said a
lot tonight so I think we may be okay.
Um but in case y'all want anything.
Okay.
>> Thank you'all.
>> Thank y'all so much. I appreciate it.